artificial wombs mimetics and genetics
such a fascinating futuristic topic
let's think about it like creation so
with humans the sperm meets the egg and
it begins gestating inside of the woman
and that's how we procreate that's how
we've been able to evolve such a complex
civilization over millions of years but
even all other biological evolution is
also experiencing some sort of creation
where they also go through a process of
reproductive cycles so all of the
species are here due to reproductive
cycles over the span of billions of
years this is a key aspect of
evolutionary biology and the reason why
we are here with as much success as we
are that we procreate and we pass our
wisdom down generationally to the next
ones that's why the generations born
today have access to internet computers
electricity food water shelter all of
these things so abundantly so let's talk
a little bit more about when people in
the past used to have children well the
way that hierarchies were structured in
the past and made it so that you really
wanted to have children you needed to
have children early you was almost as
though the earlier you had children the
earlier you had an additional asset this
asset being even five children that
would be able to help you with your
day-to-day for survival whether that be
farming for food whether that be going
in hunting whether that be going in
identifying other tools or inventing
innovating new things for people to do
new sort of ways for us to live more
optimally and more creatively and more
harmoniously with nature so people were
constantly procreating earlier in their
life
and yes do largely also to the fact that
lifespans used to be a lot shorter as
well but this necessity to procreate for
this additional asset as a human was
crucial and one could even talk about
how the amount of children that you have
was gave you more likelihood to have
super intelligent children and also that
gave you likelihood to have children
that were born with some sort of genetic
deficits as well so we have to remember
that the having children is actually
especially in the past was a critical
asset to our evolution and people used
to have those children earlier in their
lives so now we have what's called
exponential technology we have
information technology that is so
abundantly at our fingertips that can be
communicated across the planet to eight
billion of us so it went from maybe just
hmm a couple million people on the
planet and focusing on genetics was
really important to now my ability your
ability to focus on mimetic spreading
meme spreading ideas through cultural
information transfer is becoming more
and more important like I can impact
millions of people you can impact
millions if not all eight billion people
by spreading knowledge and information
wisdom across the world and so people
are focusing more on that like this
video transmission instead of me being
out at a museum or some sort of a
spiritual gathering some sort of art
exhibit or some sort of a scientific
discovery process where I could
potentially meet some sort of a partner
that could then I could endeavor into
having children with and focus my time
on just a child versus focusing my time
on disseminating this content people are
starting to live longer too by living
longer you can focus more of your 20s
and even more of your 30s on mimetics
on climbing your way up a hierarchy
in order for you to then yes spread your
memes further but also be able to
procure greater genetic offspring the
higher you up on a hierarchy not only
the less it feels like you're basically
clinging to the bottom and you're either
suicidal or you're depressed or you're
always anxious or you have severe stress
that's happening to you because you can
barely afford to have your own shelter
your own food but as you climb up the
hierarchy more and more mates both women
and men identify us competent that
you've climbed up that hierarchy and you
get better and better choices for
offspring as well so back in the day
this hierarchical climb was important
because you wanted to also get better
mates and better offspring but now you
have 8 billion people to choose from for
your offspring of course brought that
down a couple not just four billion are
of the opposite sex and brought that
down again a couple not just for your
age group and brought down a couple
notches for your preference so maybe
there's only actually somewhere closer
to a couple million people that are in
the most ideal potential for your
candidates and then again you can focus
more of your time on spreading memes to
climb up that hierarchy now with
information technologies and then more
and more likely to gain a ideal mate
plus more ideal offspring so this is a
this is a massive aspect to this
conversational point is now we live
longer
now we focus more on memes and now we're
able to go from 1 to 8 billion in terms
of communicating memes instead of one to
one child which is communicating genes
through genetics how much actualization
does someone get from having a child or
having two children or five children a
lot of time they get a lot of
actualization there's a lot of profound
aspects to having children and it's
critical to do the cell at the same time
how much profound self actualization
does someone get from spreading memes so
now this has become a new thing it was
becoming a newer newer thing with our
ability to write
Stone to paint on stone to be able to
write on papyrus to be able to then have
the era of the printing press and spread
out more of our books of wisdom across
the world so this has been evolving
really fast but especially the
information technology age and
exponential technology has accelerated
faster we're gonna get to some really
crazy things with artificial wombs in a
little bit as well because that's the
next futuristic step
so here's crazy way to look at this as
well when you're I'm I'm almost 27 years
old in what happens around this time is
that your biology is basically screaming
at you and saying find a partner and
procreate literally your biology is like
screaming at you all the time to do so
and that's one of the things that Beebe
left to figure out in their lives is
okay well when I'm around my early 20s
to my late 20s what am i focusing on my
focusing on my career my heart could go
climb or my focus on finding a mate and
having children because even at my age
of almost 27 I already have friends that
have children that are like eight years
old already or they have children that
are two years old or they're married now
right all these different things and so
again there's also people that I know
that are 35 years old that don't have
children there were 35 and there focus
heavily on their careers and climbing up
the hierarchy as well so that this
innate evolutionary biology pressure
that we have around this time period to
be like have children focus on that now
because your genes want to pass
themselves on it's such a critical way
to perceive reality because that in so
many ways is exactly what is happening
within us had even a subconscious level
that we're not always aware of your
genes want to pass themselves on so
you're being urged to procreate around
this age and this is a really important
aspect of understanding it too is that
this is a combinatoric that you're
running you identifying one of those 10
million potentially more
better identified partners for you is a
competent torque so if you procreate
with one of those out of those ten
million you're gonna have a different
offspring than if you do with another
one
so you're basically trying to optimize
your genes by having another partner
that has really strong genes so you want
them to be very sexually attractive you
want them to be very smart very
intelligent and you want them to have
other very good characteristics like you
want them to have a strong metabolism
you don't want them to be brought down
by lots of disease and that type of
stuff so you have this subconscious
program going on within you to identify
the most optimal mate and do a
combinatoric with them to produce an
offspring and this is crucial for that
child's life outcomes the stronger you
pick a partner the better the child's
life outcome is going to be and this is
a serious deal having children is a
serious deal in so many ways we have
tons and tons of children being born
into the world that don't have
financially stable parents that have
parents that are too young or not ready
to have children but they had accidents
we need to be way more serious about the
importance of bringing children into the
world and being really ready for
bringing those children into the world
financially emotionally intellectually
spiritually ready to bring another child
into the world and to give them the
right tools that they need for their
roots to get nutrients and for them to
be able to blossom and bring their gifts
to the world
we talked about this as well a little
bit earlier but it's so important that
within this hierarchical climb that
we're all going on when are you going to
identify the right time for you to have
those children so many people see these
as like bifurcating moments in their
life trajectory am I going to spend the
next four hours going out to this event
where I know they're going to be single
men or women there and I'm going to be
able to see if maybe some of them are
the right mate for me or do I spend the
next four hours working on spreading
memes do I work on continuing to grow my
career and climb up the hierarchy which
one and at what time I'm almost 27 but
what about when you're almost 32 or what
about when you're 21 or what about when
you're 42 right all these different age
points as well when do you invest more
time into going and seeking a mate and
have an offspring or when do you focus
more time on your genetic processes or
whether you're mimetic processes so
again are you focusing more time on your
genetic processes or your mathematic
processes based on what age you are in
your life trajectory and also where you
are within the hierarchy as well of
competence okay so some really crazy
things are happening around the world
with what is known as these artificial
wombs or this designer baby era that we
are approaching and so if you're not
familiar with that think about it this
way right now some of the richest people
in the world are taking their sperm and
their partners-- eggs and they're
running combinatorics but only with one
you know with two with two people with
one one partnership and they're running
competent torques in the sense that they
begin the fertilization process with the
sperm and the egg maybe let's just give
a number of 16 times so they start
making sixteen little babies for
themselves and this is all really
beginning happen to happen in vitro you
usually so we're talking about even
outside of a of a human even not in vivo
but in vitro and you can start doing
things like you can start seeing because
you make an environment for these cells
for the sperm and the egg to be able to
divide and start making to start making
for cells that are making eight cells
and you can then get to a point where
you can start screening
right at a certain point you can start
screening these little clumps of 16
cells 32 cells as they exponentially
grow you can start screening them for
their genetics so you have 16 of these
little competent torque experiments
happening and then you screen them for
their most optimal genetic States so for
example if you're wealthy enough you can
do something like this it's already
being it's already happening around the
world out of the 16 maybe a couple of
them actually have genetic issues that
have evolved so we just toss those to
the side we don't want to deal with
those then there's genetic engineering
where you could say oh those with the
issues we can actually edit out the
issues and we can actually then do the
next step right with the crazy process
which is you can bring in enhancements
so you can find the most optimal of
these 16 let's say and be like wow
that's the best one we genetically
stream that one has the most optimal
intelligence metabolism life outcome
scenarios all this type of stuff but
next is you can do things like be like
okay well why don't we figure out
because it's really hard stuff we're
still figuring this out with genetic
engineering but figuring out how to
bring their intelligence up another
notch how to bring their metabolism up
another notch how to bring their
physical strength up another notch and
then you can add those edits to the
process of making your child's life
outcome even better and so this is the
era of the designer babies where you're
literally able to create the most
advanced version of your child possible
and run all of these permutations all
these competent works to figure out
exactly how to make that best
child we all want a healthiest smartest
child that's a majorly important part of
our lives and we also want in the case
of knowing if there's a genetic issue to
knock out that genetic issue and to
produce a healthy child we don't want a
child that has a significant genetic
disease and I have an interesting
example here which is trisomy trisomies
having three copies of a chromosome
instead of two and I'm interested to
know if is this biology trying to trying
to permutate and find a new combination
okay well some people say that that that
is the case and also that it's extremely
harmful because when you have a child
that has three copies of chromosome
instead of two you can get things like
Down syndrome you can get significant
mental and physical disabilities that
prevent people from their Northstars
but could there be a biological
permutation that's happening inside of
us as we keep trying to have more and
more kids where there's some sort of a
crazy biological advancement that's
trying to combine and say well what if a
child does have three chromosomes and
they become extremely intelligent who
knows is that possible is it possible
for any of these biological permutations
to happen where a child becomes
significantly more intelligent and maybe
that's one of the things that we try to
identify as a biological enhancement
there's a lot of single single point
mutations and even multi point mutations
that are causing a severe illness of
sickle cell anemia there's a lot of
these that we're currently figuring out
how to knock out and actually make it so
that people don't have to suffer from
those but also this is gonna be really
difficult to figure out what actually
makes for an intelligent child and then
try and figure out how to edit a genome
for intelligence but that is totally
future for going in so you can take
write this wait this process that
literally used to be the fertilization
of
the new child being gestated inside of a
woman literally inside of a woman for
nine months has been the process that
it's been since the dawn of time for us
and now instead of it having to be in a
woman and literally that woman in a
sense it's a it's a gorgeous and
beautiful process for the woman to take
on the the nutritional the process of
distributing nutrients to the child and
growing this child within her it's a
very beautiful process and actually men
around the world can get better at
empathizing with women about that
process and just being better stewards
and better companions for the child
that's growing women for the woman
itself for them to be going through this
process I think but now instead of
needing to always have the child just
staying within them we have artificial
wombs now where they where the child can
just stay outside of the woman okay
interesting well what about the spirit
right this is a great question well what
happens to the spirit isn't the fact
that the gestation is happening within
the woman that there's something that's
happening with the spirit forming of the
child in that scenario could a child
born outside of the womb potentially
have issues with spirit or potentially
have issues with the soul or the seat of
consciousness right these are
interesting questions as well as their
specific aspect of just stating here
that creates a seat of consciousness
when it happens inside of the body
versus outside of the body in an
artificial womb and so when you take
this example with these let's say these
different permutations that you're
trying to run of like sixteen potential
candidates for a sperm eating an egg and
trying to evolve a child right that you
can take the most optimal one and you
can plant that in an artificial womb and
you don't even need to be a part of the
further
development of that child the evolution
of that child in terms of the next nine
months the next nine months the child's
taken care of completely taken care of
by that artificial womb and you yourself
don't necessarily need to spend that
much time taking care of it which is
very interesting versus having to
literally carry it within you and be
very vigilant about it and this has so
much to do with the crazy wealth
inequality that's happening in the world
and these crazy socio-economic
bifurcations that are evolving so
literally things that are already
happening like having our first
trillionaires around the planet these
types of things and when that happens
then what's what's gonna happen the best
this is the most wealthy are going to
get the best genetic augmentations for
their children fastest and then is there
going to be a speed of change that's
just too fast we're it's just the
children have the best physical the best
metabolism the best intelligence
characteristics that enable them to
completely outpace the other eight
billion people and then what does that
actually end up then doing for the
overall societal wealth trajectory and
the species trajectory because in many
ways people that already fly on private
jets and have five or ten homes and that
spend time on luxury yachts and that own
trillion dollar businesses that these
types of people already live just vastly
completely different lives than the rest
of us do but now we're talking about
them birthing children in completely
different ways to augment their
intelligences and make it so that their
children are even more superior than
just having access to the best teachers
and the best curriculums and the best
learning styles and the best travel
experiences and whatnot so it's to be
very vigilant about what artificial
wombs and the focus on mimetics as you
climb up hierarchies are going to do to
civilizations future so that's why we
had this conversation in this episode on
artificial wombs on mimetics versus
genetics and what the future is going to
be like with all of these things so I
greatly appreciate you tuning in thank
you I would love
to hear your thoughts in the comments
below in the episode I would also love
to hear more people talk to you're more
of you guys talk to your friends your
families co-workers people online about
these subjects about artificial wombs
about wealth inequality about genetic
augmentations about mimetics versus
genetics really have more combos about
this subject it's a fascinating one to
talk about everyone also support the
artists the entrepreneurs the spiritual
leaders organizations around the world
that you believe in supports simulation
our links are below and you can do cool
things like design cool merch and get
paid you can also join us on PayPal
patreon cryptocurrency all that stuff's
below and gold build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world I
love you very much thank you for tuning
in and I've been really enjoying the Sun
and even the bugs these insects that are
around me because you've got to practice
that sin that spirituality
life was a blessing ones buzzing in my
ear right now this is you just landed
very grateful for you all very grateful
for life let's build a bright future
together I love you very much thanks for
tuning in we'll see you soon